hola buenas tardes colega efectivamente
este hecho ha causado indignación y ya
ha provocado una oleada de protestas
importantes y contundentes
principalmente en redes aunque
organizaciones de mujeres ya han
convocado a concentraciones para
denunciar este acto de intolerancia y
violencia contra victoria salazar una
mujer de 36 años que deja en la orfandad
a dos niñas adolescentes victoria como
ya lo ha confirmado el instituto
nacional de migración de méxico vivía
desde hace algunos años en este país
tras habérsele otorgado una residencia
por refugio por razones humanitarias hay
que recordar de que esta región de
centroamérica principalmente el
triángulo norte es considerada es
violenta por la presencia de grupos que
se les conoce como pandillas
vemos hemos conocido incluso también
caravanas de cientos de centroamericanos
que van hacia estados unidos huyendo de
la violencia y en busca de mejoras
económicas también el presidente
salvadoreño
nadie bukele se ha manifestado ha
reaccionado fuertemente
tras la muerte de victoria y ha pedido
que caiga todo el peso de la ley él ya
se encuentra en comunicación con las
autoridades del gobierno mexicano para
facilitar la repatriación de los restos
de victorias
los familiares de victoria
cabe decir de que acudieron este día a
la cancillería para iniciar los trámites
de repatriación de esta mujer
salvadoreña de 36 años también la
procuraduría de derechos humanos ha
solicitado a su institución homóloga que
verifique el proceso judicial que se
lleva en contra de estos cuatro policías
y que se garantice una investigación
efectiva
como bien lo aclaraba la nota también el
presidente mexicano andrés manuel lópez
obrador
declarado o ha declarado a los medios
sentirse con mucha pena dolor y
vergüenza en un foro que precisamente
trataba de o se discutían los derechos
de la mujer es un foro de la igualdad en
el que participó el secretario general
de naciones unidas antonio gutiérrez y
el presidente de francia macro esto es
más o menos las reacciones que existen
de momento